bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre le temps
fort de cette journée
le vote solennel sur le projet de loi
transition énergétique
le sénat a adopté le texte à 182 voix
pour vous propose est bien de voir les
explications de vote des différents
groupes ainsi que le résultat du scrutin
alors vous le savez la copie du sénat
est très différent de ce qui a été voté
à l'assemblée nationale
différentes notamment concernant les
grands objectifs énergétiques de la
france par exemple sur le nucléaire est
bien l'assemblée nationale comme le
gouvernement veut ramener la part du
nucléaire à 50% dans le mix énergétique
d'ici 2025
les sénateurs de la majorité de droite
et du centre ont refusé de fixer cette
date butoir de 2025
c'est l'un des points de crispation
principaux de ce texte c'est la raison
pour laquelle les écologistes refusent
de voter ce texte je propose tout de
suite de voir dans l'hémicycle les
explications de vote
la parole est maintenant donnée à
monsieur david rachline pour les seuls
acteurs n'appartenant à aucun groupe et
ce pour 3 minutes maximum le temps de
descente n'est pas comptés dans les
trois minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président madame le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues pas de
vie sans énergie la transition
énergétique et donc dans les faits un
changement de notre mode de vie est en
changement de nos forces d'énergie la
difficulté de mettre l'accent sur le
deuxième aspect consommer mieux sans
trop toucher au premier consommer moins
il paraît en effet difficile de revenir
en arrière en ce qui concerne le confort
l'utilisation des nouvelles technologies
etc
personne pas même nos collègues
écologistes ne souhaite un retour à
l'âge de pierre en tout cas je l'espère
seulement le principal problème et non
le moindre dans ces temps de disette
financière de déficits records et de
dette abyssale et que l'on ne sait pas
très bien comment on va financer toutes
ces mesures il s'agit certes
d'investissement qui j'en suis
convaincue peuvent participer à relancer
notre économie mais il faut bien les
financer oui nous croyons en ce qui nous
concerne à la croissance verte
mais comme nous n'avons plus plus
exactement comme vous avez donné le nom
levier financier aux technocrates
bruxellois
je ne vois pas très bien comment l'état
mais aussi les entreprises publiques
spécialisées sur l'énergie vont pouvoir
financer cette transition dans le
domaine énergétique il convient de se
prémunir des idées dogmatique et si je
ne suis pas d'accord avec toutes les
mesures de votre texte madame le
ministre considère que vous avez évité
de tomber dans les pièges dogmatique du
tout énergies renouvelables
aujourd'hui en dehors de l'énergie
hydraulique les autres énergies
renouvelables photovoltaïque
biocarburants ou éoliens ne sont pas
viables économiquement pas viables
technologiquement à moins de recouvrir
le sol français d'éoliennes et de
panneaux solaires mais je doute que dans
ce cas la france reste la première
destination touristique au monde
oui il faut encourager la
diversification énergétique mais ce
n'est pas à mon sens à coups de
pourcentage à séné dans une loi que nous
y arriverons mais en abordant ces
questions sous le triptyque écologique
puis technologique et enfin économique
dans le domaine de la politique
énergétique
nous croyons à la politique des petits
pas plutôt que mesure révolutionnaire on
a pu le voir en allemagne
la fin brutale du nucléaire choix
dogmatique n'en déplaise à mes collègues
écologistes a fait bondir la produit la
production de gaz à effet de serre
aujourd'hui le nucléaire est sans doute
la source d'énergie la moins polluante
en termes d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre
la question des déchets reste
préoccupante certes mais je ne vois pas
très bien comment favoriser les voitures
électriques si on se prive de la moins
chère et la moins polluante source
d'électricité les politique des petits
pas permet de préserver certaines
filières surtout des filières
d'excellence je pense ici encore une
fois la filière nucléaire
cela permet également de ne pas se
lancer à corps perdu dans des filières
peut-être si séduisante mais peu
rentable enfin pour conclure je tiens à
rappeler fermement que nous souhaitons
que comme pour la politique économique
nous ayons un véritable état stratège
est pas un état qui brade la
responsabilité de nos approvisionnements
et de notre production d'énergie à des
entreprises privées parfois aux capitaux
étrangers
à ce titre je m'interroge encore sur les
risques de privatisation de nos outils
de production hydroélectrique contenues
dans ce projet de loi ce projet de loi
propose de nombreuses mesures qui vont
dans le bon sens mais je vous le prédis
la transition énergétique restera un
voeu pieux et non une réalité et non une
réalité pardon si vous ne changez pas de
modèle économique
modèle mondialistes aujourd'hui est
libre échangiste bref il faut prendre
conscience de l'urgence à mettre en
place le produire et consommer local
c'est l'absence de remise en cause de ce
modèle du modèle mondialistes dans ce
texte qui ne nous permet une compagne de
le voter c'est pourquoi nous nous
abstiendrons merci merci la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue madame
chantal jouanno pour sept minutes pour
le groupe u10 union centriste
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers
mes chers collègues c'est symbolique et
c'est très heureux d'ailleurs que notre
vote solennel interviennent aujourd'hui
le jour où jean louis borloo a lancé sa
fondation pour l'énergie en afrique à
laquelle d'ailleurs le président du
sénat assister c'est symbolique et c'est
heureux parce que nous sommes sur des
sujets fondamentaux devraient juste
revenir quelques instants sur ce point
on est sur des sujets économiquement
fondamentaux c'est l'avenir même de la
croissance économique qui est envieux et
quand on regarde les perspectives de la
réduction de la régression de la
productivité par exemple alimentaire
avec le réchauffement climatique tout
particulièrement en afrique
on voit bien là qu'il ne peut pas y
avoir de développement en europe
si notre grand voisin africain dont la
population va doubler n'a pas accès à
l'énergie
c'est un sujet social monsieur relevé
c'est aussi un sujet social ça a été
longuement évoquée d'ailleurs dans nos
débats puisque fondamentalement la
question du climat est une question
d'inégalité et on peut s'interroger
d'ailleurs s'il a pâti des instances
internationales n'est pas lié finalement
à une certaine forme de cynisme c'est un
sujet de sécurité il ya une étude très
intéressante qui vient de paraître qui
montre que 1 degrés de réchauffement
climatique contribue à accroître jusqu'à
7 % le risque de conflits internationaux
et c'est un sujet aussi pour nous et
vous savez que ça me tient à coeur qui
concerne notre vision future de l'accès
aux ressources stratégiques
donc la question de la transition
énergétique ou du grenelle 3 peu importe
pour la comme on veut peu importe pourvu
que ça nous rassemble cette question est
un sujet fondamental et sur ce point
l'exemple de l'afrique est extrêmement
symbolique
alors naturellement madame la ministre
les dit je le répète j'ai des regrets
sur ce texte
j'ai des regrets puisque il y avait des
sujets que j'aurais aimé voir creuse et
qui n'ont pas été creusé la question
pour moi n'est pas celle des polémiques
du débat sur la date ou pas de la
réduction de la part du nucléaire dans
le mix énergétique
cette réduction de la part du nucléaire
au sein de notre groupe nous l'avons
souhaité nous l'avons portée nous avons
déposé une résolution sur ce sujet il ya
un désaccord sur la date nous étions sur
vous aviez proposé 2025 finalement il
n'ya plus date mais très honnêtement ce
débat là n'est pas fondamentalement un
débat écologique
si on s'intéresse à la question
écologique on pourra tout à fait
conclure que la question que le
nucléaire est finalement un très bon
élève
c'est une question de sécurité de quels
risques nous assumons ou pas sur notre
territoire et je ne pense pas qu'il
faille faire un arbitrage entre le
développement du nucléaire ou sa
réduction et les énergies les énergies
renouvelables donc pour moi le débat est
d'abord un débat économique
s'il n'y a pas de modification des
signaux économiques et tout
particulièrement de la fiscalité
nous aurons quelques améliorations mais
nous n'aurons pas ce que la plupart
appellent de leurs voeux à savoir une
profonde transition écologique
aujourd'hui la france est en tête de
classement sur les prélèvements pesant
sur le travail et la production en
europe et avant dernière en terme de
fiscalité écologique
je souhaiterais juste qu'on inverse
notre classement je voudrais juste qu'on
arrive à basculer de une partie de la
fiscalité effectivement sur la pollution
est là qu on donne un véritable signe
économique pour dire il vaut mieux créer
de l'emploi que polluer tout simplement
malheureusement ce débat n'a pas eu lieu
on nous a dit pendant la loi de finances
il aura lieu pendant la loi de
transition énergétique et pendant la loi
de transition énergétique on nous dit il
aura lieu pendant la loi de finances ça
fait quelques années d'ailleurs qu'on
nous dit vous n'êtes pas la première
mais tant que nous n'aurons pas cette
profonde modification de la fiscalité
nous aurons du mal à évoluer
fondamentalement sur la question de
l'écologie deuxièmement débat que
j'aurais aimé voir un peu plus creusé
mais bon il ya eu certains
comment dire certaines réticences au
sein de l'hémicycle dans son ensemble
d'ailleurs la question de la liberté des
collectivités de leur libre droit à
expérimenter attester de leur libre
droit à ne pas être sous le carcan des
lois des règlements des décrets d
arrêter et à pouvoir expérimenter des
mesures ensuite les élus assument leurs
responsabilités si une mesure pour mener
la transition énergétique ne plaît pas à
leurs électeurs et ben ils ne sont pas
reconduits malheureusement je sais que
ce débat est constitutionnellement
difficile je le sais bien c'est pas une
raison pour le refermer
il faudrait vraiment qu'on avance sur ce
sujet parce que les collectivités sont
beaucoup plus créatif que n'importe
quelle administration quelle que soit
d'ailleurs la qualité des membres de
cette administration
mais les collectivités ont beaucoup plus
de marge de manoeuvre pour mener à bien
cette transition
et pourtant madame la ministre nous
voterons cette loi évidemment que nous
allons à voter évidemment elle a été
modifié par le sénat elle a été
améliorée il ya quelques dispositions
qui me déplaisent les fameux mille
mètres sur les éoliennes mais ça on aura
le temps de l'es2 les corriger mais
fondamentalement il y a eu de grandes
améliorations sur ce texte au sein du
sénat
il ya eu d in des améliorations sur la
question de la précarité énergétique
nous avons très nettement renforcé les
dispositions sur la rénovation des
bâtiments au sein du sénat
nous avons amélioré le calendrier il y a
eu des dispositions sur les énergies
renouvelables notamment sur un meilleur
partage de l'hiver sur une meilleure
concertation n'est ce pas monsieur
monsieur mort et il y a eu beaucoup
disposition dans le domaine des
transports
beaucoup de dispositions pour la
multimodalité pour le développement des
circulations des circulations douces et
c'est vrai que très honnêtement je
regarde avec beaucoup de regrets le
traitement médiatique qui peut être fait
du travail du sénat il ya un énorme
travail qui a été réalisé au sénat nous
avons examiné plus de mille amendements
en tout cas pour ceux qui étaient en
séance mille amendements il ya eu un
énorme travail fait par nos rapporteur
et par nos présidents de commission
et il ya eu un travail trans partisan on
a eu une écoute je reconnais madame la
ministre et vous savez je suis parfois
avare de compliments il ya une très
bonne écoute du gouvernement de
l'administration il ya eu un travail
trans partisan qui s'est réalisé au sein
du sénat et je ne voudrais pas que l'on
résume le travail du sénat à une
polémique très politique sur une date
2025 ou pas 2025 c'est pas le sujet
c'est pas l'ambition ni de la transition
énergétique ni de ce que certains
appelleraient le grenelle 3 donc nous
voterons cette loi même si nous espérons
très fortement qu'il y aura un avenir à
la question de la fiscalité écologique
et à la libre expérimentation des
collectivités territoriales ils vont
merci merci ma chère collègue
la parole est maintenant aux présidents
jean claude lenoir pour le groupe ump
vous avez la parole bien monsieur le
président madame ministre mes chers
collègues
rebondissant sur les propos qui a été
exprimée ici à la tribune le sourire est
la qualité des travaux que nous avons
menées pendant quinze jours ici dans cet
hémicycle avec une assiduité constante
avec une participation éclairée de la
plupart des intervenants
nous avons je crois fait un bon travail
un travail sérieux ce n'est pas moi qui
le dit c'est du vent autorisé qui vient
de l'assemblée nationale qui a porté un
jugement tout à fait lucide sur tout le
travail que nous avons mené et je dirais
que nous avons menée jusqu'au bout
ce qui fait que nous proposons à la
commission mixte paritaire qui allait
convoquer un texte réfléchi abouti
sérieux sur lequel nous allons pouvoir
travailler sur lequel nous allons
pouvoir également échanger avec nos
collègues députés
quelques remarques après avoir dit que
le groupe ump qu'il représente ici à la
tribune va voter ce texte personne n'en
sera surpris
une première remarque madame la mini
c'est que ce texte sur la transition
énergétique se situe dans le
prolongement de textes qui ont été votés
par le parlement depuis dix ans je
rappelle la loi du 13 juillet 2005 dite
loi pope loi d'orientation de la
politique de l'énergie je rappelle la
loi du 3 août
2009 qui est le grenelle de
l'environnement sur lequel le parlement
d'une façon assez large s'est prononcé
je parlerai également des décisions qui
ont été prises au plan européen puisque
l'union européenne a fixé à l'intérieur
de ce qu'on appelle le paquet climat
énergie un certain nombre d'orientations
sur lesquels la france est rapidement
talent inné on voit d'ailleurs dans le
texte de sur lequel nous allons
délibérer dans un instant des
dispositions qui sont déjà mises en
pratique je pense par l'union au
relèvement à 23% la part des énergies
renouvelables d'ici à 2022 même que la
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre de même que les économies
d'énergie ce sont des dispositions qui
existait déjà mais qui se trouve
renforcée par la loi qui nous était
proposé
je ne permettrais de dire que cette loi
mais connaît au départ une évidence
c'est que la part des énergies carbonées
est prépondérante dans notre système
énergétique
trop souvent il est apparu suite
d'ailleurs d'intervention venue d'un
groupe en particulier que c'était une
loi plus tôt sur l'électricité et à
partir de là sur l'explicité d'origine
nucléaire
est-ce que je peux rappeler que la
consommation d'énergie en france propose
pour 23% sur l'électricité
tout le reste c'est à dire les trois
quarts c'est de l'énergie carbonées à
partir du pétrole du gaz et du charbon
et à l'intérieur des 23 pour cent vous
avez à peine 80 presque 80% d'énergie
nucléaire alors ne réduisons pas le
débat à la question du nucléaire
ce n'est qu'une petite partie du sujet
si l'on parle des énergies carbonées il
faut parler du bâtiment il faut parler
de transport autant de sujets qui ont
été largement développée dans le cas de
notre discussion mais pour lesquels un
effort important doit être fait pour
réduire justement à la fois la
consommation et pour diminuer l'émission
d
co2 et gaz à effet de serre sur ce texte
quelques observations pour vous dire
quels sont les points sur lesquels le
débat va se poursuivre au delà de lévis
cycle dans lequel nous sommes avec nos
collègues députés
c'est bien sûr d'abord la question du
nucléaire sur l'article 1er est sur
l'article 55
je redis que nous sommes attachés à une
politique dans le domaine de l'énergie
qui préserve l'indépendance de la france
qui assure la compétitivité de nos
entreprises qui préserve le pouvoir
d'achat des consommateurs et qu'ils
soient protectrice à la fois de
l'environnement et du climat
voilà les quatre piliers d'une politique
volontariste dans le domaine de
l'énergie est à cet égard les choix qui
ont été faits il ya longtemps qu'ils ont
été prolongées par des gouvernements de
sensibilité tout à fait varier ont été
particulièrement protecteur des intérêts
de notre pays
alors nous avons sur cet article premier
rédigé un texte qui a été je crois
examiné à la loupe par l'ensemble des
personnes qui composent cette assemblée
mais également à l'extérieur et lesquels
ont d'une façon générale considéré que
c'était un texte fondateur bien écrit
qui pouvait rassembler c'est à dire que
nous sommes conscients que la part du
nucléaire baissera
quels que soient les gouvernements quels
que soient les majorités la part du
nucléaire ne pourra que baisser dans le
temps et l'objectif de 50% ne nous
contrarie pas en revanche la date de
2025 est une date irréaliste le délai
pendant lequel il faudrait fermer 20
réacteurs est impossible à tenir
c'est la honte pour laquelle sous la
plume de notre rapporteur que je
félicite ladislas poniatowski a été
rédigé un article
qui dit retrait de l'électricité
d'origine nucléaire compensé par de
l'électricité non carbonées venant du
renouvelable est donc le moment venu eh
bien nous arriverons à 50%
ensuite son article 55 c'est sur le
plafond fixé dans la loi concernant la
puissance installée
nous avons réintroduit l'arrivée pour
une échéance relativement proche 2010
est sans doute de flamanville pour tenir
compte d'une façon très pragmatique de
ce qui sera mis à la disposition à la
fois de nos entreprises et des
consommateurs
voilà quels sont les points importants
sur lesquels notre attention est fixé
sur la question de l'éolien
nous félicitons nos collègues
socialistes qui l'ont présenté un
amendement que nous avons votée
concernant la distance à respecter entre
d'éoliennes et des habitations
voilà donc une coopération une
co-construction d'un texte qui je crois
donne satisfaction au plus grand nombre
alors et demain je ne parle pas d'assez
mp je parle des prolongements qu'il faut
donner à une vraie politique énergétique
il faut mal à blâmer nice m plus
d'europe
l'europe est étrangement absente du
débat pour une raison simple d'ailleurs
c'est que en europe il n'y a pas de
politique d'énergie
chacun fait en fonction de ses moyens en
revanche les pays de l'union européenne
peuvent se rassembler dans deux
directions pour favoriser les
interconnexions et deuxièmement pour
soutenir la recherche notamment faveur
du stockage de l'énergie et notamment de
l'énergie électrique
il y à des sommes considérables engagés
des crédits importants à voter c'est
sans doute dans le cadre européen que la
recherche peut être stimulé
c'est dans le cadre européen que les
échanges peuvent se développer et donc
un plomb l'ensemble des partenaires pas
seulement le gouvernement français mais
les gouvernements de l'union européenne
à se retrouver pour fixer des axes
réaliste qui nous permettent à nous de
continuer à préserver davantage que nous
avons qui je le rappelle fait que la
france conclut après l'assaut
le pays qui protège le mieux le climat
du fait en particulier des choix
énergétiques que nous avons fait je vous
en remercie merci la parole est à
monsieur roland courteau
bonjour chers collègues
merci monsieur le président c'est le
rapporteur madame la ministre et chers
collègues lors de la discussion générale
jamais conclu en indiquant le futur
n'attend pas alors inventant le dès
maintenant et c'est bien l'objectif de
ce projet de loi dont je salue l'esprit
ambitieux son audace et sa force
merci d'avoir osé madame la ministre
nous avons aussi apprécié votre écoute
votre présence votre esprit d'ouverture
le dialogue fut fait que vraiment
fructueuse
nous avons fait du bon travail je crois
de co-construction aussi les rapporteurs
je ne sais pas si nous nous sommes
dépassés mais nous avons su dépasser les
clivages sur un grand nombre de points
passion tous hélas messieurs les
rapporteurs je salue toutefois au nom du
groupe socialiste votre travail
il y avait il urgence à réagir oui sans
doute
dans le dernier rapport du giec est
alarmant lorsqu'il évoque des incidences
irréversible et dangereuse face à une
telle situation une seule certitude
celle du choix qui a été fait madame la
ministre
le choix d'un mode de croissance verte
qui fait de tous les acteurs même de ce
changement jusqu'au coeur des
territoires avec des territoires à
énergie positive
le choix d'une rupture avec un modèle
énergétique qui n'était plus durable le
choix d'une rupture avec une trajectoire
qui n'était plus soutenable
oui il y avait bien urgence à réagir car
les sirènes de l'urgence climatique sont
de plus en plus tridente mais il avait
aussi cette urgence économique et social
et là je pense à la crise du bâtiment et
à l'effet levier de ce projet de loi en
matière de croissance et d'emploi je
pense aussi aux doigts de chacun un
logement décent à la lutte contre les
logements passoires ou au combat contre
la précarité énergétique
oui avec l'allongement de la trêve
hivernale et la mise en oeuvre du chèque
énergie ce texte ouvre davantage les
portes au droit pour tous à l'énergie
aux droits pour tous
se chauffer l'hiver oui il y avait
véritablement urgence à promouvoir
l'économie circulaire car le système
linéaire de notre économie qui consiste
à extraire à fabriquer à consommer plus
à jeter a atteint ses limites
saluons donc l'entrée de l'économie
circulaire dans notre droit positif
oui l'industrie le résidentiel tertiaire
les transports constituent d'importants
gisements d'économie d'énergie et là
aussi il y avait urgence à réagir car en
ce domaine nous sortons à peine de la
préhistoire
non il n'y avait pas de meilleure
réponse aux enjeux climatiques
écologiques sanitaires et sociaux pas de
meilleure réponse à la nécessaire
compétitivité de la france pas de
meilleure réponse pour impulser cette
croissance verte solide durable avec la
création d'emplois nombreux et
l'amélioration du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages
c'est ce qu'on appelle concilier
écologie et économie et ce texte va dans
le bon sens
oui la phrase s'étaient tenues
d'inventer ce nouveau modèle la france
se devait de mettre en mouvement la
société sur un sujet majeur aux
multiples enjeux
il fallait un texte qui nous donne
rendez vous avec l'histoire
car la phrase doit avoir pour ambition
de devenir une puissance écologique un
modèle et une référence
bref il fallait un texte qui permet
aussi d'inventer la social écologie car
il ne faut jamais oublier que si les
conditions de vie se détériorent
par suite d'un environnement dégradé ce
sont les plus faibles les plus fragiles
les plus précaires et les générations
futures qui en subiront les conséquences
les plus graves
sur tous ces points le texte a été
enrichi mieux nous avons su faire sauter
quelques points de clivage entre nous et
non des moindres je pense à la cspe sur
laquelle nous avons abouti à un
compromis en séance
vous avez rassuré madame la ministre
concernant les concessions
hydroélectriques et l'ouverture à la
concurrence
il ne s'agira donc plus d'une ouverture
sèche à la concurrence telle que
proposée en 2010 par le gouvernement
fillon
vous nous avez rassuré sur la
possibilité qu'on t'aime 6e
de prolonger la durée des concessions au
delà de 75 ans et même de 99 ans vous
nous avez rassuré sur les nouvelles
scènes hydroélectrique qui éviteront la
concurrence sèche laquelle aurait abouti
à une quasi privatisation de l'eau
barrages qui sont ne l'oublions jamais
des biens publics nationaux et
concernant les énergies renouvelables
nous soyons la mise en oeuvre des
dispositifs de participation avec les
sociétés de production des renouvelables
nous saluons aussi les mesures positives
sur l'effacement et sur les électro
intensifs ainsi à ce stade de mon propos
et jusque là jusque là le groupe
socialiste applaudi et votre texte de
loi de la ministre et les améliorations
apportées par le sénat ce qui me permet
d'ailleurs à ce stade de citer bernard
maris ce assassiné le 7 janvier à
charlie hebdo il écrivait il écrivait la
réalité de la satisfaction minimale des
besoins essentiels de tous santé
logement culture est là et il appartient
à l'humanité de la mettre en oeuvre
il faut renoncer à l'accumulation pour
l'accumulation mais il faudra du temps
ajoutait-il avant que la stationnarité
et même la décroissance soient intégrés
dans les gènes et dans ce nouveau monde
ajoute-t-il
il y aura des actifs il y aura des
économistes il y aura des dentistes il y
aura surtout des artistes
fin de citation quoi qu'il en soit
madame la ministre
avec ce texte vous avez ouvert la voie
en ce sens dommage dommage et j'en
termine par là que les deux amendements
du gouvernement sur le nucléaire n'ait
pas été adoptée
c'est là pour nous un point
d'achoppement important je le répète
nous ne sommes ni pour le tout nucléaire
ni pour la sortie du nucléaire et didier
guillaume la utilement rappeler dans les
débats nous sommes favorables à cette
énergie
qui est décarbonée et nous recherchons
un équilibre autre point de l'île
agences l'amendement sur les coupures
d'eau dommage que le sénat dans sa
majorité et oublier la violence que
constituent pour une famille une coupure
d'eau et l'humiliation que cela
représente
dommage dommage pour ces quelques
clivage vraiment car nous avons un texte
d'avant garde qui d'une certaine manière
invente le futur de la vie la mort dans
l'âme
nous nous abstiendrons mon cher collègue
la parole est à notre collègue ronan
dantec dont le groupe écologiste parole
monsieur le président madame la ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs président
chers collègues
beaucoup craignaient que le sénat
détricote complètement la loi de
transition énergétique et que nous nous
retrouvions donc cet après midi devant
un tas de pelote consciencieusement
rembobinez finalement reconnaissons le
ce n'est pas le cas certes l'ensemble
tricoté par l'assemblée nationale a
quelque peu été modifié des morceaux ont
été enlevés d'autres rajouter certains
éléments sont pour le moins rapiécé mais
il n'a pas disparu dans les étoffes
nouvellement tissé par le sénat nous
noterons ainsi plusieurs embellissement
sur la rénovation énergétique des
logements par exemple le fait de ramener
de 2030 à 2020 la date pour l'obligation
de rénovation du parc de logements
privés est une avancée forte
crédibilisant l'objectif de
réhabilitation de cinq cent mille
logements par an à l'horizon 2017
surtout qu'il est complété par
l'obligation sur un amendement
écologistes de rénovation au moment des
mutations à partir de 2030 ce fut une
jolie bataille parlementaire sur ce
point le sénat a donc fait oeuvre utile
pour crédibiliser l'objectif
intermédiaire de réduction de 20% de la
consommation d'énergie en 2030
et on ne comprend donc pas très bien
pourquoi le sénat a supprimé cet
objectif de l'article 20 de la loi ce
n'est pas tout à fait logique avant
justement de revenir sur les
incohérences esthétique du patchwork
élaboré permettez-moi de signaler
quelques autres jolies pièces cousu par
le sénat le groupe écologiste a
notamment apprécié bon après bien sûr
toujours une question de goût la
création d'une filière rep pour les
bateaux de plaisance qui permettra de
réduire l'encombrement des ports par les
bateaux et par où le droit pour les
habitants des petites îles non connectés
de choisir leurs distributeurs
d'électricité ce qui devrait accélérer
l'autonomie énergétique de ces
territoires future vitrine du
développement des énergies renouvelables
nous remercions ici madame la ministre
d'avoir soutenu nos propositions
parmi les plus belles pièces sont
évidemment aussi très fier d'avoir
réussi à accrocher l'obligation de
raccordement dans les 18 mois des
installations renouvelables ce qui
devrait accélérer leur développement
même s'il nous a pas échappé la crau
pour ne pas dire le trou de mythes
géante qui a saccagé les possibilités de
développement de l'éolien terrestre avec
l'interdiction de leur implantation à
moins d'un kilomètre de toute habitation
cet amendement surprise aura aussi je ne
sais pas si ça a été intégré
rossi logiquement pour conséquence de
geler toute urbanisation dans un rayon
de 1 km autour des éoliennes déjà
installée de réduire donc à néant les
projets d'urbanisme de milliers de
communes françaises
c'est évidemment absurde mais nous
abritons dans nos rangs quelques côtes
huriez attiré par le surréalisme
car malheureusement faire d'un ensemble
de pièces de tissus recouper disparates
un costume cohérent n'est pas des plus
aisée surtout quand certains manient le
ciseau un peu frénétiquement
nous avons ainsi un groupe spécialisé
dans les coupes et les modifications de
forme 50% de nucléaire en 2025
je coupe 63 3 2 gigawatts pour la
production du nucléaire je rehausse le
col jusqu à 64,85 gigawatts
on ne sait jamais des fois qu'il fasse
un peu froid l'hiver prochain le refus
complet par le sénat des nouvelles
tendances du renouvela
pour un repli en tête-- vers les modes
ancien dit du tout nucléaire
pourtant passé de monde partout ailleurs
dans le monde aura ainsi été une
constance du débat dans notre hémicycle
malgré la faillite d'areva fleuron du
toujours prête à porter le tout
nucléaire français avec quand même 5
milliards de passif je sais pas si vous
avez bien intégré le niveau de la somme
le sénat n'aura pas soutenu la nécessité
de développer rapidement de nouvelles
offres industrielles à l'immense demande
mondiale de développement des énergies
renouvelables mais je me rendre hommage
à madame la ministre à votre éloquence
dans votre défense de l'article 20 sur
le potentiel de création d'emplois pour
l'industrie français dans ces filières
d'avenir des énergies renouvelables
au final nous voici donc avec une
confection assez étrange à partir du
costume plutôt saignant que vous nous
avez livré l'assemblée nationale sur
lequel vous aviez madame la mise
beaucoup travaillé en intégrant les
propositions des groupes de travail du
débat national sur la transition
énergétique notamment ça a été dit par
chantal jouanno sur le rôle renforcé des
collectivités territoriales qui mèneront
réellement sur le terrain cette
transition énergétique des ajustements
nécessaires par rapport au premier
patron était effectivement à faire et je
veux aussi rendre hommage au rapporteur
du sénat qui ont souvent proposé des
retouches pertinente des embellissements
souvent soutenus par madame la ministre
régulièrement à l'initiative du groupe
écologiste mais pas seulement ont aussi
permis de montrer que nous étions
capables de travailler collectivement il
ya du positif dans notre travail
mais au final une coupe déséquilibré
impasse joueurs disparates aux coutures
fragile nous ne sommes pas dans la haute
couture ni même dans le rapiéçage il
faudrait trouver un autre nom mais à
propos de non l om c'est au final pour
le groupe écologiste art fut résolu de
cette proposition des structures et nous
voteront donc contre le costume qui sort
du sénat ne peut pas tenir bien
longtemps
certains le pensent même certainement
suffisamment fragilisé pour qu'ils se
décident rapidement car le projet reste
bien de rester à l'ancien costume du
modèle énergétique français dont
certains ici encore la nostalgie
malgré ses yeux
et le coût faramineux de son entretien
nous préférons donc retravaillé avec la
proposition initiale de l'assemblée
nationale conforme aux croquis du
président de la république c'est la base
pour créer un costume solides pour
l'avenir moderne et innovant capable
d'affronter toutes les variations
météorologiques
je vous remercie merci la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue jean pierre
bosino pour le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen vous avez eu mon
cher collègue monsieur le président
madame la ministre chers collègues
messieurs les rapporteurs nous voudrions
dans un premier temps salué la qualité
des débats qui ont animé cet hémicycle
pendant près de quinze jours
nous ne pouvons pas nier qu'il y a eu de
réelles avancées par rapport aux textes
au texte initial
nous nous félicitons aussi évidemment de
l'adoption de trois de nos amendements
sur des aspects importants du texte
s'agissant des avancées il en est ainsi
des objectifs de réduction d'énergie
d'origine nucléaire
certes pour certains le texte ne va pas
assez loin
le palier 2025 ayant été supprimée la
capacité de production ayant été revue à
la hausse afin d'intégrer le p r de
flamanville mais si pour les sénateurs
du groupe communiste il était important
d'inscrire dans la loi un objectif de
réduction de la part du nucléaire qui
nous engage dans la transition
énergétique
il fallait un objectif réaliste et
atteignable cela a été dit un objectif
qui soit en adéquation avec la nécessité
de réduire notre empreinte carbone tout
en permettant de consommer autrement
pour des usages identique et qui
tiennent compte d'une relance
indispensable de notre industrie dans le
respect de l'environnement
il en est de même en terme de rénovation
énergétique
là encore des objectifs s'ils sont aux
ambitieux ne sont pas financés mais le
projet de loi le mérite d'exquis c'est
des solutions afin de lutter contre les
passoires énergétiques
à cet égard la réécriture du dispositif
permettant la dérogation règles
d'urbanisme est une bonne chose ainsi
que l'assouplissement des méthodes de
rénovation la priorité donnée à la
rénovation des habitations des ménages
aux revenus les plus faibles souvent en
situation de précarité énergétique et de
consommation est une bonne chose
ces éléments sont en quelque sorte une
première étape vers plus d'efficacité
énergétique dans les bâtiments et je ne
doute pas que le dispositif pourra être
encore améliorée enfin sans être
exhaustif les avancées en terme
d'économie circulaire et de gestion des
déchets sont aussi à souligner ainsi la
lutte contre le gaspillage des matières
premières est une réelle avancée et nous
ne pouvons que nous féliciter de
l'adoption d'une hiérarchie dans
l'utilisation des ressources
avec une priorité pour les ressources
issues du recyclage ou de sources
renouvelables
il en est de même de l'interdiction de
l'enfouissement des déchets dans les
terres agricoles qui est une réelle
victoire pour notre groupe
cependant si le délit d'obsolescence
programmée a été confirmée c'est une
définition réduite de ces délits qui
sort de nos travaux si c'est un premier
pas dans le bon sens
nous ne pouvons faire l'économie d'un
affichage obligatoire de la durée de vie
des produits d'une extension de la durée
légale de garantie ou encore de la mise
à disposition obligatoire de pièces
détachées de plus les questions de
l'étalement urbain et de la place des
transports publics et du report modal ne
sont pas suffisamment un autre point de
vue prise en compte dans ce projet enfin
la lutte contre la précarité énergétique
reste insuffisante et le manque de
moyens est criant
ni mise en place d'un service universel
de dernier recours ni renforcement des
compétences du médiateur de l'énergie
plus grave encore la majorité du sénat a
adopté un amendement
revenant sur l'interdiction des coupures
d'eau et nous considérons que c'est une
faute politique qui
si tu beaucoup d'émotion la lutte contre
la précarité énergétique semble plus
symbolique que réelle
nous regrettons que la mesure positive
d'élargissement du chèque énergie se
fasse au détriment des tarifs sociaux
nous restons enfermés dans la logique
d'une hausse du prix de l'énergie due
avant tout aux dogme de la concurrence
libre et non faussée
à cet égard le refus de modifier le taux
de tva peu pour un bien aussi essentiel
que l'électricité est parlant pour nous
ce projet de loi s'inscrit bien dans une
démarche d'ensemble visant à la
privatisation du secteur de l'énergie
ainsi il propose un modèle énergétique
loin des principes qui ont conduit à la
construction de ce secteur en france à
la libération la péréquation et
l'égalité de tous en tout point du
territoire
ce texte organise la territorialisation
rampante de l'énergie mettant en cause
ce qui reste d'un service public
national de l'énergie
cet égard les territoires énergie
positive tout comme les pôles
territoriaux énergétique organise la
concurrence entre les collectivités et
ils skient ce un modèle énergétique en
circuit fermé voire en autarcie
énergétique
cela n'est pas le modèle que nous
défendons il en est de même de la
possibilité ouverte collectivités
territoriales d'entrer dans le capital
de sociétés totalement privée ou encore
de financer en lieu et place des banques
les travaux de rénovation énergétique le
projet de loi confirme et va plus loin
dans la marchandisation de ce secteur
renforcement du marché de capacités
renforcement du marché de l'effacement
au profit des monopoles privés sous
couvert de réalisation d'économies
dernière d'énergie et enfin
privatisation et c'est pas le moins
graves du secteur historique de
l'hydroélectricité même si madame la
ministre vous avez tenté de nous
démontrer qu'il ne s'agissait pas de
cela
ce projet de loi ne peut être lu
indépendamment
du projet de loi qui va venir en débat
le projet de loi macron qui favorise le
tout routier au détriment de la sécurité
et des objectifs de réduction de nos
émissions de co2 que dire de la
libéralisation du transport interurbain
et de l'ouverture à la concurrence de
lignes d'autocars inter urbaines
régulière vous le savez tous cette
arrivée des opérateurs privés nuira
fortement à l' équilibre déjà souvent
précaires de lignes ferroviaires dans
lesquelles les régions ont beaucoup
investi
la loi macron qui pour rappel n'est que
la mise en oeuvre de préconisations du
rapport attali que nous avons combattu
que dire de la volonté du gouvernement
de céder de nouvelles participations du
groupe edf
certes il s'agit d'un autre projet de
loi mais nous pouvons penser un texte en
dehors de tout contexte politique et
législatif l'écologie ne peut être le
prétexte pour la libéralisation des
marchés et le démantèlement de l'égalité
républicaine pour toutes ces raisons et
en le regrettant les membres du groupe
communiste ne voteront pas le projet de
loi sur la transition énergétique
même si nous le soulignons à nouveau
certaines dispositions vont dans le bon
sens et aurait sans doute mérité un
projet de loi spécifique
merci mon cher collègue la parole est
maintenant président jacques mézard pour
le groupe du rassemblement démocratique
et social européen
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous allons clore
dix jours de débats intenses et
constructifs
je ne ferai pas durer le suspense notre
groupe votera choisi unanimement à une
habitation à une abstention près le
texte qui nous est proposé
parce que ce qui compte pour nous c'est
le contenu
ce n'est pas le climat général et nous
considérons que le texte qui nous est
proposée va dans le bon sens ce texte
initialement avait pour ambition de
fixer le cadre d'un nouveau modèle
énergétique français plus diversifiée
plus équilibrée vers une croissance
porteuse de compétitivité pour nos
entreprises valorisant les nouvelles
technologies créatrice d'emplois
durables et luttant contre le
réchauffement climatique
une fois de plus le sénat a démontré son
utilité en apportant des modifications
essentielles à un texte qui suit son
examen à l'assemblée nationale avait
perdu en lisibilité en cohérence
multiplication de rapports objectifs
irréalistes dispositions parfois
incantatoire et pour répondre à notre
collègue écologiste
je crois que l'assemblée nationale avait
en partie réalisé un costume virtuel nos
commissions des affaires économiques et
du développement durable grâce au
travail rigoureux de nos rapporteurs ont
largement contribué à façonner un texte
plus équilibré et le président lenoir a
eu raison de recadrer le débat
électricité énergies carbonées et on
opposant pas la filière nucléaire à
laquelle notre groupe est
fondamentalement attachés aux énergies
renouvelables
madame la ministre je souhaite également
salué la qualité du dialogue que vous
avez introduit dans ce débat
ce qui a aussi contribué à la réussite
de l'examen de ce texte dont quelques
regrets mais qui n'en a pas a sur des
textes aussi important d'abord sur les
moyens car nous regrettons que la
fiscalité soit la grande oubliée de ce
texte alors qu'elle constitue un outil
indispensable à la réussite de la
transformation énergétique de notre pays
madame la ministre vous avez eu souvent
l'occasion de rappeler que les mesures
fiscales relevé des lois de finances
c'est vrai mais force est de constater
qu'elles n'ont pas non plus été envisagé
dans la loi de finances de 2015 la
question des moyens souvent et
légitimement été soulevé lors de ces
longs débats il reste pour nous
malheureusement bien en deçà de
l'ambition des objectifs affichés
nous regrettons par ailleurs sur un
point plus particulier qu'une
valorisation de l'hydrogène qui est une
énergie décarbonée n'est pas été porté
par ce texte nous avions déposé des
amendements en ce sens sur la nécessité
d'accompagner le développement des
énergies renouvelables
ce n'est pas contestable c'est une
véritable priorité pour le pays mais il
y a encore beaucoup de contradictions
entre les discours et les réalités de
terrain et en particulier sur les
énergies renouvelables
nous considérons que d'importants
investissements dans la recherche des
technologies dans le domaine du stockage
des énergies sont indispensables et
doivent devenir prioritaires notamment
gelé dit dans l'hydrogène sans quoi il
ne sera pas possible de passer à l'ère
post carbone et je rappelle ce que
madame la ministre avait dit lors du
débat initial le réseau intelligent
c'est pour nous l'enjeu fondamental des
prochaines années le réseau intelligent
la synergie entre les réseaux
énergétiques et numérique
car si aujourd'hui le réseau énergie et
distributeurs il faut impérativement que
demain
ils deviennent distributeurs et
collector nous avons un texte finalement
consensuel assez consensuel si l'on
reprend les exposés des précédents
orateurs et qui est assez ancré dans la
réalité l état d'esprit constructif dans
lequel ce texte a été abordée a permis
d'en maintenir les sens tout en
rééquilibrant certaines dispositions
lorsque cela était nécessaire sur la
lutte contre le changement climatique
savons que c'est un là aussi un
véritable impératif la stratégie bas
carbone prévue par ce projet de loi nous
a paru et en cohérence avec nos
engagements européens et internationaux
relatifs à la réduction des gaz à effet
de serre vous vous êtes fait une
défenseure fervente de l'écologie
positive et non punitive et je me
félicite et l'ensemble de mango que vous
soyez rallier à la sagesse du sénat
suite à l'adoption d'un manque d'un
amendement du groupe rdse en commission
concernant l'exclusion de la stratégie
bas carbone des émissions de méthane
entérique naturellement produit par les
ruminants
je ne représente je ne reprendrai pas
l'excellente formulation de notre
collègue requiet sagesse sans laquelle
les agriculteurs qui joue un rôle majeur
dans la transition écologique de nos
modèles de production de consommation se
serait vu injustement sanctionné au
moins médiatiquement sur le nucléaire et
j'en terminerai sur cette question qui
nous est cher je crois que le sénat est
parvenue à une solution plus réaliste
plus responsable en affirmant d'une part
la nécessité de diversifier notre mix
énergétique en permettant le
développement des énergies renouvelables
d'autre part avec la nécessité d'une
mise en oeuvre
progressive raisonnée de cette
diversification par la suppression de
l'horizon 2025 initialement prévue par
le texte sur la réduction de la part du
nucléaire
cela permettra de tenir compte de quoi
de la réalité des réalités techniques
scientifiques économiques et ce afin de
préserver notre compétitivité
le pouvoir d'achat des français et notre
indépendance énergétique
concernant les énergies renouvelables
nous nous félicitons également des
améliorations apportées grâce à
l'adoption de plusieurs amendements en
particulier des nôtres sur la géothermie
la biomasse ou encore l'éolien et la
simplification des procédures permettant
l'exploitation c'est d énergie
contribuera à leur développement
pour conclure malgré ces quelques
réserves madame la ministre et chers
collègues je les dis la quasi unanimité
de notre groupe à l'exception d'une
abstention approuvera ce texte issu des
travaux du sénat lequel à travailler
vite et bien
malgré la quantité d'articles de ce
projet merci merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
il va donc être procédé dans les
conditions prévues par l'article 56 de
notre règlement au scrutin public sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi relatif à la
transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte
ce que tu as ouvert dans quelques
instants il aura lieu en salle des
conférences
ce en conformité aux dispositions de
l'art du chapitre 15 bis de notre
instruction générale du bureau une seule
délégation de vote est admise par
sénateurs je déclare le scrutin ouvert
pour une demi heure et je suspends la
séance jusqu'à environ 16 heures heure à
laquelle je proclamerai le résultat
la crc reprises entouré de trois
secrétaires jackie pierre collette mélo
et bruno wiel
je protège en les remerciant les
résultats du scrutin numéro 106 sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi relatif à la
transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote
nous avons eu 1 343 votants 216
suffrages exprimés pour l'adoption 182
contre 34 donc le sénat a adopté le
projet de loi relatifs à la transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte
voilà mes chers collègues le résultat de
ce scrutin
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci pour ce
vote magnifique qui engrange des
avancées décisives définitivement
acquise
merci pour vos explications de vote
aussi venant de tous les groupes qui
toutes ont souligné la portée historique
d'une réforme qui dépassant les clivages
politiques vise à engager la france dans
un nouveau modèle énergétique de façon
irréversible en donnant à tous les
secteurs concernés industrie bâtiment
services le cadre stable pour investir
et pour créer des emplois dans tous les
domaines de la croissance verte en
prenant nos responsabilités pour lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique et pour
faire du modèle français celui de
l'excellence environnementale exemplaire
avant la grande conférence de paris pour
le climat où les dirigeants du monde
entier devront prendre leurs
responsabilités pour faire comprendre
que nous avons deux patries la nôtre et
la planète
cette révolution de la croissance verte
qui s'accélère porté par cette loi
enrichi par vos travaux et les actions
concrètes et financière qui
l'accompagnent est le fruit vous le
savez d'un travail minutieux attentif
déterminé à l'ecoute de multiples
instances allant des conférences
environnementale au débat citoyen à la
contribution des ong aux actions
concrètes et réussie de nos communes
départements et régions et je tiens à le
dire dans une volonté de rassemblement
au grenelle de l'environnement et des
lois qui l'ont précédé ainsi qu'aux
contributions
du conseil de la transition écologique
qui rassemble toutes les parties
prenantes du dialogue environnemental
mais surtout je tiens à saluer
l'excellent travail accompli par votre
assemblée et la grande qualité du débat
démocratique sur tous les bancs
la grande qualité du débat démocratique
sur tous les bancs que j'ai eu plaisir à
animer avec vos chefs de file roland
courteau jean pierre bosino ronan dantec
jacques mézard chantal jouanno et le
président jean claude lenoir ainsi que
le passionnant travail de votre
commission des affaires économiques de
votre commission du développement
durable que préside hervé maurey ainsi
que celui de vos rapporteurs louis
et ladislas poniatowski qui n'ont ménagé
ni leur temps ni leur énergie
il n'y a eu ni vaines polémiques ni
politique politicienne mais une vraie
hauteur de vue une volonté commune de
projeter la france dans un futur bon
pour elle sans effacer les légitimes
différences de points de vue tout
respectable et que je vais encore mais
force est de rapprocher d'ici l'adoption
définitive de la loi
nous avons je le crois a débattu dans un
esprit qui fait honneur à la démocratie
j'entends par là non seulement que les
points d'accord et les points de
désaccord ont été amplement et
minutieusement argumenté mais que
toujours notre motivation première fut
la recherche du bien commun
vous avez je m'en réjouis confirmés la
plupart des dispositions majeures du
texte que j'ai défendu en première
lecture à l'assemblée nationale
et d'ailleurs les 250 amendements sur
plus de 1000 examiné 250 amendements que
vous avez adopté ici on pour 80% d'entre
par ma voix fait l'objet d'un avis
favorable du gouvernement au cours de
vos débats c'est dire l'esprit
constructif qui a prévalu alors bien sûr
avec quelques 5 ou 6 alinéa qui reste à
finaliser et donc un nombre très
marginal par rapport aux 66 articles de
ce texte et au 1005
alinéa comme l'a fait remarquer le
président didier guillaume
en effet ces quelques points restent
très marginaux et comme il est d'usagé
ils seront soumis à la commission mixte
paritaire qui va se pencher dessus dans
une semaine et je ne doute pas que le
parlement sera donnée sans tarder la
plus grande force aux mouvements de tout
ce qui va nous permette de faire de la
france forte de la législation la plus
avancée car la plus complète d'europe
une puissance écologique
donnant l'exemple chez nous et donc est
donc capable de convaincre et
d'entraîner à l'échelle européenne pour
construire l'europe de l'énergie évoquée
par le président jean claude lenoir et
mondiale pour apporter des réponses aux
défis climatiques et j'observe
d'ailleurs que les réformes proposées
pour construire une économie bas carbone
sorte de renforcer à l'issue des débats
dans les deux assemblées et je vous en
remercie une nouvelle fois avec
notamment la performance énergétique des
bâtiments pour faire baisser la facture
et engager les travaux grâce au crédit
d'impôt et à l'éco prêt à taux zéro par
exemple deuxièmement la priorité donnée
aux transports propres pour lutter
contre la pollution de l'air et protéger
la santé
troisièmement les objectifs zéro
gaspillage zéro déchet et notamment dans
les plus 200 territoires à énergie
positive
quatrièmement la montée en puissance sur
les énergies renouvelables grâce à de
nouveaux mécanismes de soutien et de
simplification
cinquièmement la lutte contre la
précarité énergétique avec en
particulier le chèque énergie
sixièmement le renforcement de la sûreté
nucléaire et enfin le pilotage
démocratique du mix énergétique et son
rééquilibrage par le passage de 75 à 50%
du nucléaire dans l'électricité alors
sur certains points très peu nombreux je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure
et comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
préciser au cours des débats
je souhaiterais bien sûr en revenir au
texte initial
dès lors qu'il corresponde ont dès lors
qu ils correspondront à l'intérêt de
notre pays et je sais pouvoir compter
sur un bon dialogue entre les assemblées
pour bien finaliser ce texte rien les
plus forts disait victor hugo qu'une
idée dont l'heure est venue cette idée
dans la france et dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui ce sont les nouvelles
valeurs du développement durable qui
oblige à agir ensemble localement et à
l'échelle planétaire pour la lutte
contre les dégâts du réchauffement
climatique
la reconquête de la biodiversité la
qualité alimentaire et la santé publique
pour le progrès environnemental
indissociable du progrès social et aussi
de la compétitivité de nos entreprises
qui attendent ce texte avec impatience
pour investir et pour réconcilier enfin
les exigences du temps présent et celle
des temps à venir celle des générations
futures pour lesquelles nous agissons
ensemble alors une remarque pour
conclure quand on marche seul on se dit
qu'on peut aller plus vite mais quand on
marche avec d'autres on va en vérité
plus loin voilà pourquoi je souhaite
qu'au bout du compte sans que chacun ne
renonce à ce qu'il est mais aussi sans
confondre l'essentiel et l'accessoire
les élus de la nation joignent leurs
voix pour que nous réussissions avec
tous les français
cette belle révolution de la croissance
verte et des nouveaux emplois qui vont
avec
je vous remercie merci
merci madame la ministre voilà pour ce
vote solennel sur le projet de loi
transition énergétique et croissance
verte
vous avez pu suivre les explications de
vote des différents groupes au sénat sur
ce texte un texte porté par la ministre
de l'écologie ségolène royal je vous le
rappelle le sénat a adopté ce texte pour
la suite de vos programmes vous
retrouvez votre émission politique
preuve par trois ce soir perrine
tarneaud reçoit le député européen front
de gauche jean-luc mélenchon très bonne
journée à vous sur les chaînes
parlementaires